more than two decades ago Britain's
Royal Society of Art decided something
needed to be done with a prominent but
empty space smack in the middle of
London's most famous Trafalgar Square
it's an open plinth where a statue was
meant to stand the Society said that it
should instead be a showcase for works
from a rotating group of artists this
year it was the turn of an American who
came up with a tribute to the lost
heritage of Iraq destroyed by Isis from
London Roxana Saberi reports in London's
historic Trafalgar Square a new
sculpture tells a story of the past and
points to an uncertain future designed
by American artist Michael Rocca wits
and unveiled by London's Mayor Sadiq
Khan this week the winged bull stands on
a platform known as the fourth plinth
what's become Britain's most prominent
stage for modern art what's important is
that people look at this great piece of
art and talk about it and you know ask
the question why is the original
destroyed what is it that makes you feel
so insecure about themselves that
they've destroyed pieces of odds the
story of the sculptor began nearly three
thousand years ago when statues of
winged animals with human heads called
Lama su guarded the city of Nineveh in
what's now Iraq three years ago in a
museum in Mosul Isis militants took a
drill to one of the statues denouncing
it and other priceless artifacts as
signs of idolatry
I saw the destruction a lot of the Lama
su but I thought about the people that
live near Nineveh and live near Mosul
then that's where I kind of understood
the horror rock ooh it's decided to
fight back he recreated the Lama su
using modern materials more than ten
thousand empty cans of date syrup they
tell another story
Iraq state industry once thriving has
withered from war in London it rains a
lot like today are those date cans not
gonna rust
I have date syrup cans that are nailed
to the outside of my apartment in
Chicago that is with
the Chicago weather for the past two
years and if those cans can withstand
Chicago weather does that mean that they
can with down London weather I I'm not
placing any bets the grandson of Iraqi
Jews forced to flee their homeland in
the 1940s Rakha wits grew up in the u.s.
hearing about his cultural heritage
while seeing images of Iraq torn apart
as a war zone as a battlefield and
there's so much more so 12 years ago he
began rebuilding Iraqi artifacts
destroyed in war using middle-eastern
food packaging and newspapers he and his
team have remade more than 800 so far
the lamassu is the latest for London's
mayor the winged bull symbolizes the
strength of his City which has faced its
own attacks by Isis why is it important
to have this sculpture here in your city
this for me is an act of resistance I
like some resistance against the tyranny
of religious fundamentalism 20 million
people are expected to see the Lama su
over the next two years at the end of
its run here in Trafalgar Square in two
years if the Iraqi people would have it
I would love for it to go back to her
off to Mosul if they would have it it
would be an honor for CBS this morning
Saturday Roxana Saberi London I just
love what he's doing just remarkable
yeah food packages into our date Kenz
yeah take cans and as I like what the
mayor says he calls it an act of
resistance it is